we've been throwing around the term
emoluments for a while now and let's
reset that conversation when we talk
about the emoluments clause in the
Constitution
what we're talking about is article 1
section 9 Clause 8 of the Constitution
and what that does is make it illegal
for people in the federal government to
receive gifts and things of value from
foreign States and monarchies and the
argument is that Donald Trump is
violating the Constitution because he's
receiving a ton of things of value from
other countries including money when
foreign dignitaries pay to stay at his
hotel in Washington DC admitting that
it's to curry favor with them and this
is now going to be like the tenth line
of investigation against Donald Trump
this is separate from Trump Russia this
is separate from the inauguration fraud
that's being investigated this is
separate from obstruction of justice
it's separate from the illegal hush
money payments it's a totally different
line of inquiry this is being
investigated at the state level which is
also important since state level
criminality cannot be pardoned away by
the presidential pardon power which is
of course federal what's going on is
that Attorney General's attorneys
general rather in Maryland and
Washington DC have so far sent 38
subpoenas to different parties related
to exploring if Donald Trump has
violated the Constitution's emoluments
clause Trump's Justice Department is now
panicking doing anything they can to
stop this from moving forward the Trump
Justice Department is saying this must
be stopped by a district court by the
January 3rd deadline for those 38
witnesses to respond to their subpoenas
Trump already tried getting this
dismissed at a lower court level lost
that appeal and when you look at the
legal brief Pat as to why they are
saying this needs to be stopped
the Justice Department is saying if you
don't stop these 38 witnesses from
responding to their subpoenas this could
be irreparably harmful to Donald Trump
think about that why would merely
knowing about his finances be
irreparably harmful Pat unless he's done
really sketchy things and noticed how
with all these scandals the emoluments
the hush payments to mistresses that
broke campaign finance laws the Trump
Russia collusion angle we're no longer
having a conversation about if Trump did
it if Trump committed crimes it's really
just transitioning to what are we as a
country gonna do about it that's exactly
right and what the conversation now
includes is the Justice Department
saying if you look at Trump's finances
this will cause irreparable damage to
him why would just looking at someone's
finances damage them unless there's
something really bad in there which
brings us back to the tax return
question if you intrusively looked at
the minutiae of most people's finances
you wouldn't find irreparably harmful
evidence right if you intrusively looked
at my finances maybe you could say you
know David you said that you donated two
hundred and fifty dollars worth of
clothing to charity last year you really
should have valued that at 225 not 250
right that's not irreparably harmful in
any way if merely looking at someone's
finances would do them irreparable harm
that explains why you see these panicked
documents from the Justice Department
saying no no no you've got to stop this
right away we can't have Maryland and
Washington DC looking into whether
Donald Trump has violated the emoluments
clause which he pretty damn obviously
has what do you think would be exposed
if these 38 subpoenas are responded to
follow me on instagram and let me know
at David Pakman you can also follow the
show on instagram at david pakman show